this is a clip that was released by the
national pulse it is a leaked clip from
Tucker Carlson's show where the capital
police chief said that it was a that it
could be January 6 may have been a
cover-up let me play this clip for you
I'll just give you guys a warning it's a
little choppy for some reason but uh
nonetheless it's very important so let
me play this rational and not give a
number statement obviously but the facts
that you're describing are shocking
that was a state reason why I've had a
lot of people ask me you know why did
you write this book I tried to do what I
can to get the truth out yes you know
they didn't want me to testify in uh in
February February 23rd at the Senate
hearing they don't want people to still
currently in the positions but he'll
actually had to go in and talk to a
friend of mine on one of the oversight
committees say I will come there in
person I want to be there I want to
testify so I'm glad you think I'm
reserved I'm you know to be honest with
you I'm a little pissed off
um because it has to happen if if people
were reporting intelligence correctly if
I was allowed to do my job as the chief
I got a significant experience if I was
allowed to do my job as a chief we
wouldn't be here today this didn't
happen then see how you figure out your
land Basin in public and it's all you
know everything appears to be a cover-up
like I said I'm not a conspiracy
theorist but when you look at the
information intelligence that it had
military had uh it's all watered down
I'm not getting intelligence support
National Guard in advance I'm denying
National Guard while we're under attack
for 71 minutes you're in a fight yeah a
fight for a couple of minutes one minute
I was gonna say 60 seconds three minutes
let me tell you it wears you out my
officers were fighting for 80 minutes
before the the protesters
wait can I say so you described this as
a failure to get the intelligence to the
people who needed it but it sounds like
worse than it sounds like they were
hiding so intelligence and that's what
I'm getting at is
did something to happen and kind of
wanted something to happen it doesn't
it's not a far stretch to begin I don't
know what the other explanation is
you know it's it's sad when you start
putting everything together and thinking
about the way this played out uh it gets
for concern what was their end goal you
look at you look at what's happening was
that their end goal I don't know
well I mean there's no question that
would happened on January 6th has has
really helped the Democratic party it's
bravely politicized the US Military
and the intelligence agencies and the
FBI and those are all I think bad for
America and violations of
but they're all good for the Democratic
party that's the fact so it's very it's
a very choppy clip unfortunately but you
can make out most of what uh what
matters and this is the former police
chief of the Capitol Police saying
someone could have wanted this to happen
it may have been a cover-up and then you
look at what's going on now with the
Trump indictments and I think anybody
any reasonable person who's been
watching everything that's going down
would agree
The Simple Solution is
they wanted January 6 to happen to
weaponize it because they needed some
way to stop Donald Trump because they
know they can't win an election
here we are yeah
I mean I'm not a conspiracy theorist
I'm not I usually believe that there's
an explanation but if you look at the
facts of the case what happened on
January 6th and compare that to what the
charges against the January 6 defendants
were and then contrast that with the due
process violations that these people
faced and then the political Capital the
Democrats have gained for all this I
mean
it almost seems like he's stating the
obvious we're just desensitized to this
because we've been dealing with it for
two and a half years now
yeah so you know that's the point I was
making the other day people will ask
like how did a country get so bad you
know insert country the Soviet Union
Nazi Germany like how did it get so bad
took years took a decade took longer so
when something happens like Donald Trump
gets indicted here's what I think
I think they indicted him on the tax
stuff first because they know what
they're doing
if they came out and had died of trump
on January 6th outright it would be a
shock to the system that would be bad
for them it would snap people to
attention so they do an indictment not
that big a deal it's like a tax thing oh
who cares right then they do a
classified documents thing
okay well that's a little bit bigger wow
it's Federal but then ultimately it's
like yeah okay whatever now they do the
January 6th thing they're still not
remanding Trump into custody
the sheriff in uh in Fulton County said
that Trump will be perp walked and he
will get his mug shot he will receive no
special treatment
it's possible that the real romantic
custody will take place in Georgia
but they do it all in increments so that
you are desensitized to it every step of
the way but they want Trump to flee
because that's another January 6 type
thing
you get him to do it and then you can
blame him and make him look like the bad
guy again look he's still breaking the
law yeah but imprisoning uh
whether whether they're good people or
bad people about history we have tons of
stories of people who are imprisoned got
out and then took over
the president from jail from Exile let
me read you this timeline
coincidence on March 16th the oversight
Committee in the House of
Representatives
revealed the Biden family payments that
we all know are criminally corrupt the
day after that on March 17th Hunter
Biden admitted that the laptop that we
all knew was his was in fact his
the day after that
president Trump announced that the
Manhattan D.A would indictment would
indict him which they did then on June
8th
the FBI
um the FBI an FBI document alleged that
Biden and Hunter you know were involved
in that bribery scam for five million
dollars the next day Trump was indicted
on the classified documents on July 26th
the hunter plea deal the one where he
was supposed to get immunity to any
other charges ever in the history of his
life that collapses the day after Trump
was indicted
July 31st Devin Archer testifies before
the house again and then the next day
Trump was indicted again yeah I don't
think so but the big the the the the the
Smoking Gun is
the third indictment which was
additional charges in the classified
document case because they had already
indicted him then the hunter Biden plea
deal thing happens then they're like uh
we're indicting Trump again for the same
thing it's like okay you they really
need another indictment to cover this
one up I just don't understand why
there's no aliens too right any anything
to distract from it uh you know I want
to know why DC male mayor Muriel Bowser
has never had to explain why she said
yes we'll take National Guard but only
if they don't have any weapons right
like there were so many things that led
up to this that seemed strange to me
that Nancy Pelosi never asked for
additional security at the Capitol like
why are they not as accountable for what
happened as theoretically Trump or
anyone else like why are only certain
people being asked to account for the
decisions they made on that day that put
people in danger right like if you had
asked for proper security Nancy Pelosi
or Muriel Bowser then there would have
been something else the fact that you
didn't seem suspicious to me the fact
that no one is asking you to explain it
seems worse
yep I think they're counting on the fact
so think about in 2020 this doesn't have
anything to do with January 6 for a
second think about in 2020 when parents
were watching over their children's
shoulders on Zoom school and like they
were seeing critical race Theory like
your if your child's white they're
racist if your child's black they're
oppressed they were seeing the
transgender ideology and parents were
really shocked by that because a lot of
parents thought oh that's happening in
California that's happening in New York
but that's not happening like in our
neighborhood in our elementary school in
my child's classroom and they saw that
it was and this it was this huge mental
shift that you just saw sweep the
country all these parents that thought
they were Untouchable because they
weren't in this radical leftist hotbed
and then they realized that it was real
I think we're at that point with January
6 that for a long time people have been
afraid of being labeled as a conspiracy
theorist and because of that we've
forgotten that sometimes there are
conspiracies sometimes like what is a
conspiracy it's just a concerted
criminal act right that there are people
in power who are trying to do bad things
trying to violate our rights and I think
people collectively are starting to
realize that January 6 is one of those
things that it wasn't just oh the
radical right-wingers who are claiming
that it was a that it was a false flag
or something like that they're like wait
a second this actually does seem like it
could be as bad as as some of us have
been saying the whole time yeah and
we're seeing a really big shift in
people's minds I think one of the first
times she was on this so marjor Taylor
green pointed out that basically
everyone who's arrested during the 2020
Summer riots was let go and they never
faced any charges like we are singularly
focused on this one thing and there has
to be a reason for that right and I
think you know uh we saw it in the clip
someone gains from when they obsess
about January 6 and they try to turn it
into
something right there there is political
momentum and I think Tim talked about it
the other night you know if Trump had
treated uh the May attack at the church
in DC a little bit differently perhaps
The Narrative would have been slightly
differently uh I think that's one of the
things we have to credit uh left-ween at
Ling left wing activists with is that
they really know when to obsess and make
loud uh something that they are going to
make the lead story for the rest of the
year in this case it's generous X
someone did bring up an interesting
points uh just peachy in the Super Chat
saying Tucker did not use microphones
like that on his show and I just looked
up quick set images and sure enough yeah
Tucker never used uh microphones like
this I don't know what that means
perhaps the the video could have been
faked or something like that but I have
no evidence that's the case this would
be a particularly difficult video to
deep fake because it's extensive but
considering how much time it's been it's
been January since this book came out
it's entirely possible someone made an
elaborate deep fake can someone clip the
original interview when it was released
slowly change it it could be why the
audio is so so choppy or whatever but
yeah they were trying to record it
locally so that it wasn't
I don't know leaked I think the simple
solution is just that this one-time
Tucker used these microphones but I have
no idea
don't know I just I just looked after
Carlson today and the images of everyone
he's had on every single image none of
them have that none of them have those
mics
so I'm like when did he ever use those
he didn't seem to have also of course it
was a different show unless it was uh
meant for an audio release and they just
happened to have filmed it
credit to his detail-oriented fans were
being like those aren't the mics
I feel like we should subtly change
things in this room and see if people
notice this this j6 man it makes me
think like if I was in Nazi Germany in
1933 or 1934 what would I be doing to
speak out against the Nazi party rise to
power would you be speaking out and how
would I be doing it because they didn't
have citizens couldn't really grab a
microphone and go on the internet they
didn't have that kind of power yeah we
do but at the same time
people have uh can be drowned out
everybody has the microphone so everyone
is yelling over each other it is faster
but back then the the means of you
speaking out would be to make flyers and
posters or like to print a Zine or to
write something and then share it so you
got to stand out that with you saying
how people are all talking over each
other I guess that's for me why I'm
taking why I'm deciding to get into
shape because if I can make a really
good movie that people want to watch
then at least I'll be standing out and
people will be looking at my microphone
a little bit more than others well you
got to go where the money is right so
you got to go hang out in Malibu and
then hopefully you bump into you know
say Robert Downey Jr and then he's like
I like your style and then he puts you
in a movie and now you're famous yep now
you're famous and then you come out and
start talking about how the war in
Vietnam is bad and then one day on your
way to the hotel some guy jumps out and
shoots you oh okay thanks for laying the
uh that path in front of me which is why
you know what your options are I know
like do I rail against the military
powers of Earth until I die or do I just
try and make a great life with an
awesome family and go live on an island
I feel like there's both right like and
in this position you can talk out speak
about the things that you believe and
ask questions but I think change happens
at home and so there's a value in saying
like no matter what culture tells me I'm
going to live myself live my life you
know jointly hopefully with a partner
weird in a way that I feel like is
Honorable we're here for one reason I
think that's happening right now is
because of one thing
the founding fathers are the people who
said we are a moral and just people and
we Demand right we we have these rights
there inalienable and we must fight for
what is right for us and our families at
Great personal risk sacrificing their
blood and treasure and even in some
cases their families putting their
families at risk so that they could
fight for what was best for the entirety
of this nation
and then the mentality changed at some
point now the advice you're given is
just keep your head down and make money
ignore all of this and where we are now
is the average person today says I will
not risk myself my life my sacred blood
and treasure or my family they were
founding fathers whose children's uh
children were kidnapped whose families
were kidnapped to use as a leverage to
for prisoner exchanges whose homes were
seized by the British by the crown who
cities that were entirely occupied and
they were forced to flee and today you
have people saying well I can't do that
because I have a family and I can't put
my family at risk it's like okay well
you're the opposite of the founding
fathers and perhaps I know easy for me
to say I don't have kids but I'll just
make that make sure you understand that
like the founding fathers were like even
if it means my family is is kidnapped
even if it means I die even if it means
I have nothing left to my name I stand
for what this what what must be and
today
it's inverted today it's I'm going to
lock my door hide and hope that it
passes over and it's that people are
doing well even the poor people are
doing well because of fascism because
we've bought off half the world of the
slave trade of the half the world mining
these Rare Earth minerals and stuff for
us that's China yeah and in like the the
Congo like the I don't know Cobalt mines
yeah jeez it's disgusting so truly
fascism is is is dangerous in that it's
peaceful or can be very peaceful and
people have been Sedated by this but I
think it's really simple
the the currents the the current way of
life that we have you know you can work
for an hour you know if you're like a uh
the average American salary you work a
couple hours and you're gonna go have a
Hibachi dinner with your family life is
easy so nobody wants to risk it
that's it let me go back to what Ian
said before though when you ask like
what am I supposed to do am I supposed
to have a microphone and have the
loudest voice am I supposed to hide away
with my family like what if how am I
supposed to fight back against this
because we are living in a unique point
of History like no we're not in Nazi
Germany like you can't replicate
anything exactly in history but there
we're at a dangerous point in our
country right where if this if if what
happens to Trump if he's criminalized
for free speech I mean you and I all of
us sitting here have to wonder okay
we've questioned the same things about
the 2020 election like are we next like
where does that like what's the limiting
principle on that like we all could be
on the line at the whim of a government
and I think this is one of the things
that the Republican party has lost sight
of this is one of my biggest critiques
with the Republican party is that there
is a just use of government right we
often conflate the idea of a limited
government with essentially no
government
and that's not what limited government
means limited government means a
government with enumerated powers that
is accountable to the people that is run
by the people it means that it's not a
dictator that has unlimited Authority it
doesn't mean that there's no just use of
the government and we as Republicans
have forgotten that we've we've we've
demonized anything to do with government
oh we don't government involved in that
we don't want to use government for this
we'd rather use family and free market
and all of that which is fine but we
also have to use the government to fight
back against these things we are not
just by ordering our families properly
going to be able to abolish the
administrative State we're not just by
sitting here behind microphones going to
be able to recapture our education
system there are things we have to use
the government for the just power of the
government for to recapture if we want
to re if we want to stop what the left
is doing to our society and if we want
to reclaim our society which was which
is supposed to be
um how the founders envisioned it right
so you and I should I mean even if we
are I know I'm more right-wing than you
are but we should be holding our
politicians accountable for that because
everything can't be done on an
individual basis I know this is what
conservatives have told us for the past
50 years that everything's just about
like us and our families and yeah that's
important but it's also using the
government and if we did that we'd be a
lot more successful I'd like to break up
Corp a lot of Corporations especially
the tech corporations they're just too
too monopolistic Google alphabet I love
you guys thanks for letting us stream
right now but come on the corporation is
way too big yeah Google Google you got
to break them up Mata you got to break
them up X you're cool but can stay but
what they did with Rockefeller was they
went into Standard Oil and broke it up
into like eight oil companies the
Rockefeller is still a piece of so he
became even more wealthy and influential
after the breakup so we have to watch
that knowing that we can't break up
alphabet the same way that's why I
advocate for freeing their software code
because it's kind of like you reduce
their power you create
um an opportunity for the market to
compete if the code is available and
whoever has the best means of like terms
of service their their organizations
will win out but I think we need
government that because otherwise it's
gonna people would resort to sabotage
and I don't want to do that and I don't
want to boycott's not enough thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time